هنا تجمع عشرات صحفيين الافغان في مقر
جمعيه حمايه الصحفيين للاحتفال بيوم حريه
الصحافه العالمي وقد غلب على الحفل طابع
المطالب من السلطات في كابول لاتخاذ
التدابير فوريه لحمايه الصحافه والصحافيين
مثلا الحريه الصحفيه التي تمتعت بها
الصحفيات في السنوات الماضيه انتهت بل
وضعت السلطات تحديات وعراقيل امام عمل
المراه في الاعلام المرئي من بينها ارتداء
البرقع يحتفل الصحفيون الافغان بهذا اليوم
في وقت قد توقفت مئات المنافذ الاعلاميه
في البلاد جراء مشاكل اقتصاديه وذلك بعد
توقف الدعم الخارجي منها بعد استاهلات بعد
التحولات الاخيره في البلد توقف ما يقارب
من 200 من المنافذ الاعلاميه فقد توقف عن
العمل 55 محطه تلفزيونيه ومئه وتسع محطات
للاذاعه 21 وكاله اعلاميه وخمسه عشره
صحيفه من جهته اعترف عبد المتين قانع
المتحدث باسم وزاره الثقافه والاعلام
الافغاني والذي اشترك مع الصحفيين في هذا
الحفل بان مشاكل مختلفه تواجه الصحافه لكن
الوزاره تسعى لحلها
لن اقول ان الصحافه لم تواجه مشاكل فقد
واجهت مشاكل امنيه وفنيه واقتصاديه لكن
مسؤولي الصحافه الحاضرين هنا يشهدون اننا
سعينا وسنسعى في المستقبل لاحتواء تلك
المشاكل
يعترف الصحفيون الافغان بان حريه الصحافه
من المزايا الايجابيه في المجتمع ويناشدون
السلطات بتوفير البيئه المناسبه لهم
للقيام بمسؤولياتهم الصحفيه بكل الشفافيه
ونزاهه عبد النادر العربيه كابول لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات